[Music]
welcome to cloud on air live webinars
from Google cloud we are hosting
webinars daily my name is Brandi ow and
today we will be talking about
magnifying the value of G suite with
chrome enterprise and joining me today
is Christopher Jones you can ask
questions any time on the platform and
we have Googlers on standby to answer
them let's get started thanks brandy so
today we're here to talk about the value
of adding Chrome Enterprise to your
existing G suite deployment so why
Chrome Enterprise because cloud native
productivity and collaboration deserves
a cloud native endpoint with all of the
built-in security efficiency and
intelligence
what is Chrome Enterprise chrome
Enterprise includes Chrome OS the
platform that powers Chrome devices like
Chromebooks Chrome browser the default
browser used on Chromebooks and the
Chrome enterprise license a per device
management license allowing management
of Chrome devices at scale with
integration to third-party emm providers
chrome enterprise press G suite means
smart intelligent collaboration without
compromising security assistive
experiences that help enhance end-user
efficiency reduce downtime for your
users and reduce security risk from
fewer out-of-date endpoints and data
protected in the cloud the value isn't
just imagined we engaged Forrester to
study existing Chrome OS and G suite
customers and they were able to quantify
these benefits 30 minutes per user per
week and reduced downtime due to more
efficient cloud native products and
increased mobility that helped avoid
costs from lost productivity a 15%
improvement and helpdesk efficiency with
device and productivity suite management
in the same console leading to easier
remediation a $100 per user in legacy
technology savings due to easier rollout
and ongoing management and a 20%
reduction in endpoint security incidents
due to Chrome OS built-in security
furthermore analysts from ESG evaluated
how much organizations can save when
switching to Chromebooks with Chrome
enterprise based on the elimination of
common IT tasks total device savings can
amount to four hundred and eighty
dollars per device outside of the cost
of hardware and licensing themselves so
let's take a look at the factors that
contribute to these savings starting
with security with Chromebooks and
Chrome Enterprise automatic updates and
sure devices never fall out of date and
always have the latest security features
safe browsing deters users from visiting
dangerous sites that may include malware
or phishing attempts fan boxing isolates
tabs and processes if a vulnerability
does get through and verified boot
ensures the OS is a known safe version
every time the device starts since data
and profiles are stored in the cloud
with G suite Chromebooks can maintain a
negligible on device data footprint
results speak for themselves you had
zero account hijackings using
Chromebooks G sweet and two-factor
authentication for two-factor
authentication we have security keys I
plug into your mobile or device or
laptop and complement your password
these security keys cannot be broken
like old tokens again we've had zero
account hijackings using the solution
another key benefit of Chrome Enterprise
and G suite is simplicity created for
users when dealing with cloud native
endpoints devices boot quickly usually
in less than six seconds updates run in
the background so the user isn't
disrupted or faced with downtime that's
up to 30 minutes per user savings
according to Forrester cloud-based user
profiles enable users to log in to any
device and have the same experience
making them highly shareable and making
it easy to replace a broken device or
enable grab-and-go or loner scenarios
and finally and
we save time on sending versions back
and forth and reconciling changes 90% of
G suite files in enterprise accounts are
shared and 74% of time spent in Google
Docs is collaborative likewise we're
also focused on creating a simpler and
more efficient experience for IT less
time is spent dealing with legacy
technology like patches and software and
sauce cycles G suite and Chromebooks can
both be managed from the cloud-based
Google admin console
meaning reduced overhead and ease of use
for IT smart defaults on policies help
limit the time it takes to configure
your organization for example most
security settings are on by default
finally you can manage devices with
existing third-party tools such as
VMware Citrix and more finally Chrome OS
helps build on the intelligence already
found in G suite focused on reducing
mundane tasks for the user with G suite
users are able to leverage smart reply
and smart compose to easily get through
emails or use the explore function in
sheets to make the most out of their
data sets
all the while Chrome OS performs tasks
like auto adjusting screen brightness
based on ambient lighting or optimizing
power consumption and memory management
to adapt to that user's work habits and
much like Google Drive helps to suggest
files for quick access Chrome OS is
designed to enable an efficient search
experience for example device launcher
is optimized to recommend apps based on
recency and relevancy it can search
across apps web G suite and on device
files with intelligent rankings based on
context for example files you usually
access only at a specific time of the
day as you can see G Suite customers
across many regions and segments are
adopting Chromebooks let's look at a few
in detail in the US appliances
manufacturer roll pool has completely
overhauled its endpoint fleet by
equipping its workforce with Chromebooks
in G suite
the numbers speak for themselves square
adopted pixel books which allowed staff
to take advantage of the G suite
productivity apps and move away from
hard drive storage an MEA utilities
provider
Veolia implemented its sada wad which is
secure anytime anywhere any device
program with the goal of moving its
workers to Chromebooks and G suite as a
result they've been able to connect
their global workforce more efficiently
and drastically reduce the amount of IT
overhead required finally in a PAC
service NSW was able to greatly reduce
the support hours required to maintain
their Microsoft environment when
switching to Chrome Enterprise and G
suite cloud-based services enabled them
to eliminate unnecessary additional
layers and collaborate more easily
cloud-based applications are becoming
more and more prevalent and more and
more organizations are planning for
their move to the cloud to help soft
watch came up with C bar a tool which
shows real users application usage thus
providing the relevant data for
decision-makers C bar can help recognize
the following cloud workers or workers
who are ready to move to the cloud today
potential cloud workers or workers who
could potentially be cloud workers
desktop workers or workers that use non
web applications to perform their jobs C
bar displays the exact level of
dependency on non-web as well as web
applications to enable decision makers
to design a practical plan for the mass
adoption of Chromebooks additional
functionality of C bar includes the
following editing applications lists or
defining which applications can be
blacklisted compatible or watch listed
application tab which demonstrates which
users use each application machines tab
provides machine information and which
machines belong to which users office
usage tab which demonstrates how many
users use office
locations and finally macro usage tab
which demonstrates how many users use
files with macros if you're interested
in getting started check out the
Forrester TEI report or start a trial
Chrome Enterprise that you can use with
any Chromebook thank you please stay
tuned for the live Q&A and will be back
in less than one minute
you
welcome back we're
to some Q&A questions first question is
do Chromebooks work offline that's a
great question I think Chromebooks have
definitely had a reputation in the past
of being internet dependent most of our
fleet is a high memory high storage
device with powerful processing which
means you can actually run applications
in real time on the Chromebook without
any internet connectivity
additionally you can work with your
files that are saved locally on the
Chromebook storage or in your Google
Drive in offline mode so we have offline
mode for Gmail and we also have offline
mode for Drive you can view and edit
Docs sheets and slides using the offline
mode and it's really as simple as
installing a Chrome extension and
activating offline mode I'm a frequent
traveler and both Gmail and drive
offline are tools that I leverage quite
frequently so that's question one let's
move on to the second question does
Microsoft Office work on a Chromebook
well we hope you're doing most of your
editing in Google Docs formats but we
understand there may be a one-off need
to work in a Microsoft format you can
save Microsoft native formats on your
Google Drive and in local storage on
your Chromebook
there are really three main ways to work
with Microsoft files in the Google
environment on a Chromebook or in Drive
the first is through your web browser
the Chrome browser and with a sync
client the second is to install the
drive sync tool in your Microsoft
instance and the third is to upload the
Microsoft file to Google Drive or on
your Chromebook and use office
compatibility mode so you can do all of
your editing in Google and move
seamlessly back and forth between Google
format and Microsoft format interest
number 2 yep that was great um there's
another question here asking about how
Chromebooks
up-to-date so Chromebooks get automatic
updates from Google from the cloud every
six weeks and so it really takes the
onus off of IT admins to manually patch
and update the devices at the same time
IT admins have complete control over how
those updates happen for example you can
pin some devices to the current version
if there are testing and validation
cycles that you have to go through or
you can also time the update so that
they're not happening when all of your
users are on their devices so while the
updates are happening in the cloud and
takes the onus off of you you can also
completely control how that happens and
then we have another question here do
you need antivirus software for
Chromebooks so there's many layers of
built-in security on a Chrome device
that actually precludes the need for
antivirus software and so a few examples
of that are on the App layer all of our
apps are read-only as well as the
extensions so that they can't modify the
OS the sandboxing process we talked
about earlier isolates malicious apps
and extensions and so it really limits
the attack surface available on a
Chromebook on the OS level there's a
concept called verified boot which
whenever the device starts up will
always try to detect whether that
version of the OS is safe and if it's
not safe then we don't allow the
Chromebook to go into boot mode and then
finally on a Chromebook all of the user
data is encrypted with our hardware
security module and that's built into
every Chrome device that we manufacture
and because of the fact that users can
install executables on a Chrome device
that really reduces the chances of
malicious software getting installed
onto your device alright great it looks
like that concludes the Q&A list thank
you for tuning in
visit cloud on-air to discover more
content from google cloud experts thank
you
[Music]